bonjour à tous alors ce que je vais vous
montrer maintenant c'est un teaser d'une
vidéo très particulière que je vous
prépare depuis des mois c'est une vidéo
pour fêter mes 10 millions d'abonnés
youtube un court métrage réalisé par
ludovic ça fait vraiment des mois que je
travaille dans cette petite fiction
j'investis beaucoup de temps là dedans
donc j'espère que vous allez vraiment
apprécié j'ai pas trop envie de spoiler
ou d'en dire trop donc je m'arrête là je
vous montre juste et quelques images si
vous êtes impatient comme moi que ça
sorte de méta un petit sam jetables
voilà pour me montrer un peu votre
puissance et me donner la force
et puis nous on se revoit très très
bientôt sur le youtube français ciao
je
[Musique]
bonjour je viens parce qu'en fait j'ai
un problème je ne parle pas ou youtube
heures désolé je ne peux rien faire pour
vous maintenant laissez moi j'ai du
travail
d'accord vous parez vous êtes le
spécialiste mois le compteur de ma
chaîne youtube est bloqué et je sais
plus quoi faire
à combien 9 millions 999 1999 vous avez
dit combien
pour norman cours
norman es-tu prêt à pénétrer dans sa
chaîne youtube et sur fond d'achats
youtube sera pas jamais supprimé
là-bas la vidéo faire les courses halo
reach
tu as vu matrix 2 c'est pas pareil ah
d'accord
[Musique]